all right so guys the first variant that
was diced just was won by
another eric so now we are playing the
second variant which i have not told
them both about and there's an
additional rule in that variant it's the
variant that i have created from my own
imagination it's called
poison porn guys so poison power okay
listen carefully it's a complicated game
all right i want to listen very
carefully so
both of you will tell me each
both of you each will tell me one pawn
of yours which will be poisoned for
throughout the game right
okay if the opponent captures your
poison pawn
they lose the game hold on okay
you cannot poison the center two pawns
oh okay hold on
if a poison pawn this is a new rule chat
a poison pole
can never capture any piece and
the last rule a poison pawn
if it captures a poison pawn
you win that's the only piece you can
capture
do we know each other's poison pawn you
don't know so what will happen is
first you will defend you will close
your ears levy will tell me his poison
pawn
then levy will close his ears and you
will tell me your poison pawn then you
both will close so i'll tell your chat
so what does
what are your poison one so the chat
knows but you don't know oh i should
hide my chat then
yeah so you hide a chat let's play fair
one more question
can a poison pawn promote yes if a
poison pawn promotes
then uh it loses all the power and the
poison pawn can't take anything
but the other can take anything so how
do we know like if
if i have my poison pawn and i want to
take his pawn but i don't know if it's
poison but i do it anyway
and it's not just poison pawn then you
lose because you cannot capture
okay yeah you get it sounds good so okay
so eric will first tell me his poison
pawn so levi please
okay be honest be honest just give me
thumbs up when he's ready
eric uh you can tell even the chat can
hear what what's your poison bomb
oh don't look at you no no
i'm telling uh oh okay uh i'll give you
guys
i'll choose the f pawn okay cool yeah
all right okay uh see you poison my
my i don't know why i'm trying to come
up with a strategy
uh my b-pawn okay cool all right
okay eric ah where's my thing
okay all right uh cheating eric you
heard me
no i i had my headphones out please
don't look at my screen because on my
screen your both poison points will be
highlighted
oh okay sure right sure cool so i'm
ending the google meet
guys these are the poison pawns as you
can see on screen
and you guys cannot see on screen yes
oh dear um this is really hard man yeah
it's epic it's epic trust me it'll
you'll get the hang of it it'll
get epic got it it's your poison pond
um you can keep asking me the rules
again and again if you get confused
so the poison pond can't be captured if
he captures my poison pawn
he loses yeah a poison pawn cannot
capture any pawn
uh unless it's a poison pawn uh
and it's not the center two pawns that's
the it cannot be the center yeah
okay
jesus so he's like it's very very
very crazy and if your pawn gets
captured
okay got it there's gonna be so much so
much tension in this game
and also there's time like i can flag
him right so yeah
that's usually the only way i can beat
eric he's too strong
psych psychological warfare oh wait wait
you're trying to psych me out i wasn't
even paying attention i was trying to
figure out my
my development scheme that's okay eric
bye that's okay
i'm learning the okay
um wait the poison pawn can capture
stuff no
will you call it okay you'll call it so
if like
eric yes if every place c takes d5 and
that turns okay got it
okay let's go here i think black already
slightly better
i'm so happy i can control what pieces i
can move now
it's amazing and wait sorry
about about promoting yeah if you
promote a poison pawn it loses all its
powers
oh okay good to know
i'm like coming up with some big brain
strategies here
i'm just not gonna take anything all
right let's just play blitz no pawn
captures
and we just
eric he muted himself oh he did oh did
you hear me
i can hear you yeah okay he muted
himself
are you enjoying yourself so far i'm
trying to but i don't know
i don't know what you're trying to do to
me what does that even do you kind of
paranoid
it can't be that's just bad isn't it why
not wait why
but now i'm gonna get like a massive
pawn storm and then you're gonna be too
scared to take all my pawns
cap cap cap cap cap cap i'm just going
to push all my pawns towards you and you
you're not going to know which one to
take that's the thing
yeah have fun
you're kind of right i'm a little bit
afraid now yes
okay let's go here hmm
yeah of course you would push because
you're you're way too scared but see
you i know you're too scared like i'm
not too scared to take something
and embarrass myself oh wait
really yes it's just
i don't like this time disadvantage it's
very i'm very i'm nervous man
it's it's it's so scary you know there's
another layer in this now
yes and my chat is spamming emotes like
rap god
you know oh
[Applause]
man i don't i don't i don't like this
actually i'm like
i'm very stressed out oh this is very
very stressful
no captures have been made both players
extremely scared
i'm trying to think like eric rosen but
it's impossible like i don't
i'm trying to think like me too but it's
hard to think
to keep track of
this move
some captain has to be made because it's
getting too
so tense it's it's definitely gonna be
me i'm i'm definitely gonna be the first
one to uh
to capture i think
uh
so the probability it's basically one
and six
that was a good move kind of
i forgot which pawn i poisoned for
myself no i just remembered
what are you calculating uh eric um
[Music]
i wanna i wanna take his pawn but i'm
not sure
the center pawns cannot be poison guys
that's true yeah
i'm just fascinated how much eric is
blending into the chroma filter
oh i sometimes when i'm scared i act
like a chameleon
that's okay or an octopus did you know
octopus can blend into their background
what i didn't know that can you tell me
more about that for the next two and a
half minutes
there's a netflix documentary all about
this octopus and it hides from its prey
by blending in
to things it's fascinating wow
so much tension has it ever been so much
tension in any position
what kind of tension are we talking
about pg-13 intention
okay yes oh
man why you want my stuff dude
yo i have an idea what if i go don't do
it
oh is eric gonna believe my bluff that
that's my pawn
that i poisoned or is he going to take
it
because if he doesn't i'm more
interested in just winning her queen
oh that's interesting okay
hmm i don't know how you intend on doing
this
um
take on b5 eric take on b4
or f4 or g3
or h4 okay you lost your chance
okay the queen is attacked now
man this is so tense
who will break first guys who will break
who will take the risks first
um remember guys what's at stake a video
an entire video
but i'm i'm a plus one right
yeah so i love you
i'm going to do it oh
i'm doing it oh so
wait his pawn could be oh no
i don't think i want to take that i just
did it big risk big reward no no you you
you um so now you know which which one
is not poison
because otherwise i would lose
automatically if my pawn had been
poisonous oh that's actually true so
that's probably
safe to take
oof nice nice risk and now the risk has
paid off guys because
levy has gotten his in his rook
oh and i know that eric's a pawn wasn't
poisoned
yeah and also
hmm
[Music]
hmm
hmm
last 5k crazy stuff about to happen
so much pawn tension so much tension
which one will you take
queens are exchanged guys who will break
first
it's gonna give so much information
who's gonna break first
oh that's smart thank you
i know that pawn's not poisoned eric
i know it's not poisoned okay take it
you can take it as a matter of fact i
won't
no
you know what i've nicknamed eric rosen
what the god of counter play
i thought he was the god of asmr man
he's both
i'm so scared
see this is the problem though we can
just do nothing
i'm taking you're talking
is there increment oh there's no
increments there's no increments there's
no agreement
again you're safe you're safe
guys both the poison bonds are still on
the board and now it's all down to time
and there you go
[Music]
zero two zero guys uh
that was so intense
what was your was something on the
king's side or was it your b-pawn
it was i i think yours was your c pawn
and mine was my b-pun
oh mine was my f his other f-fun
wow okay that was my second guess but
wait how did i never take your f-pawn
you you just didn't take it you had so
many chances too i was so disappointed
you could have taken it like with check
at some point
oh yeah wow i conveniently oh man
yeah g5 was watching and then i and then
i locked it yeah i just played too
slowly
wow 2-0-2-0 and well now because there's
a special request from the chat they're
saying that they would like to see you
guys play with the old rule ones
so let's have a rematch if you guys are
up for it okay sure the old rule is that
a poison pawn can't take that's only
change the potent pawn can take anything
but again at the same time
yeah it can take it can take this time
let's play with this rule and if a
poison bond takes a pausing point you
win
the poison pawn takes a poison point
okay got it
it's the same rule just the fact that an
opposing point can't take upon okay so
can't take anything basically
so it doesn't actually it changes a lot
of things
oh it does it it does because okay yeah
so now it's a lot more powerful
yeah now it's more powerful let's go to
the store rematch
to 2-0 eric you have uh you have an
advantage
let's see if levi can break through wait
sorry i'm just if if
my poison pawn takes his poison pawn i
win
you'll win i win okay got it all right
um so i'll have white this next game
right so okay i should tell you my
poison phone first
okay i'll take my head but i'll i'll
look for your thumbs up
yep okay okay
uh come on
my
eric okay all right all the best
lovey
bye nicole oh sorry sorry seriously
i don't want to leak anything yeah okay
um
we'll make it uh the f pawn
again cool
cool guys come back all right eric good
luck okay
you too too much tension but then now
the pawn is more powerful
i hope eric has pissed again the scent
the center pawns don't mean anything
right
yeah center pawns cannot be poisoned
chad but i diagonally
[Music]
yes i know this system and team scandi
[Music]
oh you're terrible dude
i just want to make you oh
i know what you're going to play too i
know i know i know i knew it
i knew it that's like i knew you would
play eva
it is correct what what's up
no no uh his his deep one is a stand up
on right
yeah it used to be an e pawn but it
transitioned yeah but i think e5 is
still the best move
right i mean probably i'm just getting
the center pawns we're done
we're done we're getting rid of the
centerpoints this is going to make the
game a lot more interesting
so 10 000 people watching at least we
need 10 000 likes guys please increase
the likes 2000 more hey people let's
let's
get semi ten thousand youtube subs i
don't know if i can do that i don't know
if i have that power yet but
guys go uh go sub on youtube sub all at
once
yeah also go watch the diss track you
might not understand hindi but it's the
greatest piece of musical work
ever thank you there's like symphonies
and stuff but
okay now i can tell you which pawn is
poisoned
okay it's going to stand upon
okay
i just i know i have to play fast for
this game now question if eric beats me
now probably
like it's over like i have to make it
but if i beat him do we have one more
game so i have a chance to tie of course
of course
okay
okay
okay both players are playing very
normal game until now
but there's an extra layer in this
yeah oh there is
wait don't hurt me oof
b4 has been pushed let's see
hmm
eric is just so boring he's like i just
don't want you to hurt me
like that was such a bold move
actually taking there would have been
really smart by you why
because you can take and if i take i
lose
oh like i probably wouldn't have taken
back to be honest but
then you would have forked me and i
would have been losing material if it
wasn't your poison pawn
you're right oh man that's so tense oh
boy
oh boy i'm ooh it's nice
i like this tension i like
to do my movie of course hi my name is
better than me oh my god
i'm so confused
i like i told someone what's up today i
said it's gonna be a stream
of two professional comedians and asmr
god
yeah and then he's bad joke and i was
like oh so you are the asmr guard
okay okay ah this move don't give me
information actually
just attacking levi just wants content
i just played too slow last game you
know i was waiting i was comple i was
completely winning if i don't kill
myself tonight i'm going to leave
thousand years
um
wait sorry aren't you losing upon a
piece
now it's a fork and one minute
oh that could be your poison pond too
yes i take pages of play book of master
me um
and you'll never know right
oh that's true
if you take a poison pawn on its
checkmate you still lose right
yeah okay wait really wait that sounds
kind of unfair but it's it's
point of game it's variant bryant
yeah i'm i'm like i'm like tense i'm
cold i'm quite
too i'm trying to like i'm trying to
like like throw punches not with eric
just like with my wallet
it has only one and a half minute uh
it's insane it's insane what's happening
in this game
because i know everything let's try and
bluff you
what i'm up a piece you can't bluff me
good luck with this brother you know
i play bishop
i will just negate the effect of your
poison pawn
by immobilizing it
wait so that wasn't your poison pawn or
was it
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
but it's okay i was ready to get rid of
pawn anyway
ah the time advantage will win by itself
right so
no but i mean how do you recover from
down
this amount of time oh i shouldn't test
it because eric plays so fast
sorry by check meeting you but how you
do this
i'm gonna try really
i'm doing some russian accent and
spending some time because guys
actually it's it's very easy guys to do
to do to do
you just guys guys guys it's
it's obviously everybody misses a niche
but i i can't
see like i when i talk that fast i just
go russian by default and
i don't like it
so much tension guys so much tension now
you're losing
i feel really uncomfortable here
it's your time levy you have to win this
otherwise it's gone you have to make a
video
oh i'm gonna win what are you talking
about come on
come on i i've i've you know i'm used to
being in positions against eric i have
material advantage so i will convert it
wait what oh no my bishop hahaha
please
what what what why is
uh no no no guys in this in this variant
a poison pawn can kill
uh anything
i'm i'm confused and and now i'm also
distracted
oh that wasn't that was a very smart
move actually thank you
too much tension
eric is also very fast enough thank you
man look he caught up he caught up on
the kid didn't time up on time he's
about to though maybe
if i'm not careful oh no
but actually my night
eric is so funny too yo what what what
is what
what is this move oh my thing
wait this is really bad yeah you're down
a lot of pieces i
i mean it's your queen oh my god your
queen is trapped
the queen is kind of trapped no
it is completely trapped i mean yes you
have yes
yeah he's gonna go for this and and hope
that i take his pawn but
i'm too smart for this uh what's not
even my thing
that's a lot of what no
oh but h7 could be his pawn yeah you
have no idea
okay then i'll just kind of do
i'll just i'll mate you without taking
any puns don't meet me
last eight seconds guys
that's it it's over it's over look at
this
wow is that your point no it's not
it's not checkpoint oh no my queen
like was it was the was the poison pawn
your f on yes yes it was
oh summit you should have just let you
should have just let because i just read
it but but did you get
get the hint from there no no i mean i
was never going to take his pawn it was
way too risky
and uh did you know which uh pawn was
poisonous
eric was it the no i mean the b pawns
probably
either a b or g no it wasn't g on it
you have caught up to one how did you
know it was my g pawn
um there was a moment when you played
like g5
i just assumed you were trying to
overextend it
and then oh wait really i like i thought
i gave you like no information all right
chad i'm going to take you off emote
only for like a minute so you guys can
tell me how you're doing how you guys
doing really no but g5 is protected
i mean i i guess brg because uh i these
are your two most extended pawns
but you know there was such a smart move
eric on already which move
that i was like i told chad dude this is
so smart that was
move number uh here move number 17
where you go rook a8 instead of taking
inviting him to take
uh trying to tell him that it's not my
poison ball well i was scared that maybe
his f pawn is his poison pawn
no his epon you mean uh well
his e-pawn yeah that used to be an
f-pawn
you're saying you're saying but then if
it was if you capture it with your
poison point you win
a poison pawn capture oh that's true
actually yeah
so yeah so by not taking it you actually
invited him to take because if it was
poison
you could have taken it without a
consequence right i think i i
acknowledged this at some point and then
i tried to make him think that my f pawn
isn't my poison pawn because i didn't
take on v6
and you didn't take it why didn't you
take it over there on move
number 17 f7 yeah it's way too risky
what there there's no row i'm already up
a piece so my logic was i'm up a piece
i'm up a minute why should i
risk taking upon all right so let's have
a last game guys
last game let's see if uh levy can tie
it with eric
or if eric can has to make a video or if
uh let me have to make a video
okay my chat uh went a little bit wild
they they broke free and then somebody
tried to
uh snitch on someone else apparently
someone was trying to tell me what i'm
not i'm not reading chat when this is
going on but
you have 30 000 people watching right
now what
someone just told me in my chat wow
that's epic those don't like
[ __ ]
thank you so much let everybody know uh
they were i don't know they were
no there were only uh 12 12 000 people
watching
yeah it's still a big number that's a
big number watching
very grateful very grateful grateful
what am i saying anyway
so guys let's play last match uh levy
versus eric
time to score even same did you like
this way and more of the previous one i
think this is much fun though
this is this is pretty fun yeah it turns
into a lot of just
regular chess but i i like this one even
though i lost
i lost also yeah all right let's go
let's go let's continue with the seven
chat you are right
much more fun variant so if eric wins is
done and if i win we have to play a
tiebreaker or we both have to make a
video about each other
maybe that okay so eric all the best
yeah well eric you're gonna have white
right so i should uh
yeah okay
okay let's do let's do c
okay cool okay bye-bye
um okay this is big
it's big big big um
and i will pick
let's pick uh c c pawn
okay okay guys so everything is set
and let's begin those to the last match
of today let's see let's have it
there we go let's go yes let's go guys
this is it
okay
no scandi the anti-scandi opening
yeah i'm trying to think are there any
meta openings that i can play
let's like
last game we it was very open so we
traded
center puns very early and i feel like
this time
this time you know what the
have you heard of this this is uh the
nasal laws gambit
oh what is that oh this is gonna be your
next youtube video
well maybe but it's this isn't real
chess i don't know how strong
it will be but it's a cool gambit
i sack a pawn for developments what
would spell one do a sec
what if i go here oh
could your h-pawn be i mean it doesn't
matter because even if it is i would
just i would just say this is theory oh
great fantastic yes
nasal bomb nasal swabs or maybe
nozzle wasps i think it's true i can
read it n-a-s-e-l-w-a-u-s
i don't know how to spell it but it's
something it's a nasal
i want to make very interesting position
oh
i once had a older russian i am after a
chess tournament or i think he said this
to my friend he said
in the end they they drew in like 15
moves like end of tournament you know
no no com you know no prize money they
just drew and the guy comes up to my
friend and goes
you know it's a very interesting
position because it's completely equal
and i was like why would that be
interesting how does that make the
position interesting at all
but he seemed to have a different you
know opinion
this is a very interesting position guys
yeah but the problem is it can get
locked very quickly so we're both kind
of jostling here
how to not lock it right that seems to
be
oh this is very oh my god i don't know
what to do about this
um and i got 96
oh
uh almost it's just
it's like world championship of i am
right man this is actually
psychologically
i know you know
you know what i i don't i don't know
eric i'm nervous i'm just talking
this is just just it's just what they
told me in commentary school
okay
okay i'm muting i'm talking to the chat
no semi tell me moves
i want moves
what's the best move here
this this
the problem is this guy yeah
this is so confusing because i don't
know if
you're bluffing me or if i'm bluffing
you i feel like you put it like you're i
think your poison pawn is your h pun i
think it's something super ridiculous
and like it it's not a logical pawn
because you wanted to
or like your apon or something although
those those objectively would be the
worst ones
right because like
yeah that would have no they don't take
part in the game so in reality it's like
yeah it's got to be ah it's my central
pawn
ah wait because i know your center pawn
can't be poisonous
wait but that's a terrible move eric
because i just take your bishop oh
oh pawn's captured diagonally
wait eric what i could just take
unless you're so smart you figured out
my c
pawn is poisoned and your c pawn is
poisoned and if you take oh
that's some crazy [ __ ] right i'm not
doing it no no
oh man wait you see pawns do you just
tell me your poison pawn
no no no but now i'm scared why
i'm scared are you that smart
i just i just realized pawns captured
diagonally
and there goes my bishop
you know what no no i'm not buying i'm
not buying i'm not buying
oh
oh you said something but you you muted
yourself so
no idea oh you have secrets no no i'm
i'm just talking to the chat
okay
oh you're talking about levy
oh could it be your g pawn
this is so confusing
wait this is terrifying
i'm dying oh no my knight
and my bishop
wow whoa we are
it's nice
this is the craziest position i've ever
seen
i'm so confused right now
[Music]
i i think the eval bar is like plus
seven probably
actually no technically it wouldn't be
it's probably lost for white because
you know the chess.com chat is going
crazy can someone explain what is
happening
it looks like a queen's gambit variation
that's because it is
okay this this i have no choice uh-huh
guys the loser if it is levy has to make
a video
about eddie's best chess game so a lot
of things are on stake
what what
this is just positional sacrifice
your bishops don't scare me no
wait well that was oh i can't even keep
track of what pawn is where anymore
where did that pawn come from that's the
e pawn
okay that's still the one okay you
haven't cross captured anything
why is eric playing this bad guys
writing chess.com chat
hmm
how am i down two bishops
it's eric it's it's our usual games
last 35 seconds guys
your c pawn your c pawn was poisoned
eric
[Music]
no draw
all right i win i win rice i win oh no
yes
oh
i tried to make it so obvious that it
wasn't obvious
except it kind of was oh man eric
what brilliant play what brilliant play
that was such a throw
your c pawn was poisonous too correct
yes yes because i kind of i realized
pretty early like when i played c5
i can't really take on b6 or d6
because then you take back with c pawn
and you win you know
levy you missed such a brilliant
opportunity when he gave you the bishop
on move number 11 he takes bishop takes
d6
why don't you just stick with the queen
well i don't know if his pawn is
poisoned like
oh yeah that's what's up there like i
like i don't know because i could have
been bluffing
yeah yeah that's there oh man this was
such an intense match oh my god i'm so
ah man it's okay it's okay you know in
many in many ways i have to say in many
ways
somebody whoever loses today yeah is
going to make more money and
yeah yeah i'm saying we're like i'm
going to make more money now because i'm
going to make a video which is dedicated
to eric
that's true eric you should you should
have you're going to get
all the ad revenue wow yeah such good
content
you want to split it like 60 40 i mean
can you just like
tell people to check me out maybe if
they want yeah sure
okay that would be nice guys uh uh guys
can you please
mod spam the link of uh the twitch
accounts of both these legends who have
come and had so much fun with them an
insane match i hope you really like this
variant did you
this is funny a lot of fun no this was
different